Ooh, I'm sorry for thrusting too hard, honey. That is what you're
having. That is what you're having. >> the voice I did,
BY THE WAY.
OH, LISTEN. IT'S 2020 LISTEN, they come in all shapes and sizes.
Tell them, Dickers. Dickers would know, as he is a harsh BDSM
master who's had triple dick with a partner of the last 8 years.
Oh. Dickers, how long do you last? 3 minutes? Yeah, Dickers,
how hard is YOUR DICK ASS?
NOW, TURKEY TOM'S EX HAS just dropped a document. Turkey Tom
had some allegations dropped. Two women came out on Kiwi Farms,
started dropping allegations, including some DMs with him. One
of those people is his most recent ex. Uh probably the strongest
allegations with the most evidence are the ones that he is into
age play. So, allegations that he's into age play, allegations
that he was
aggressive, that he would be get like physical during sex in
a way that they didn't necessarily consent to. Now, the thing
you got to know about Kai, okay? No, no, no. I've got the link
to the Google Doc. The thing you got to know about Kai is that
she is,
according to Larex, about to start pursuing a streaming career.
Pursuing a streaming career while being the person who's like
trying to cancel a big streamer, not a good idea. What's up?
How's it going? Who this? All right. Hey. We're starting to,
you know, build up this theory that it's Kai that's lying. Okay?
You notice the way she goes through this language
Yeah, yeah. What's this about the
Okay. So, if there's no age play dynamic, if there's nothing
here at all that could come back to bite them in terms of logs,
why don't you just go Yeah, the age play thing's totally made
up. Why don't you leave it ambiguous? Can you read the ambiguity?
Can you read So, I'll I'm going to do this. I'm going to say
cuz there's two ways to read this, one that's not ambiguous and
one that is. So, why would you say there's been a message circulating
claiming that Tom and I participated in age play, which is just
a blatant twisting of the truth.
why is it a twisting of the truth and not a lie? Because they
didn't engage in sexual dynamics together. Yeah, but that's not
the allegation. No, no, but the the allegation is that they engaged
in role play. Specifically that Kai liked to act like a little
girl.
But if she likes to act like a very submissive, like sub.
There's like a kernel of truth there. It feels like a statement
made by a lawyer. Never expressed through age-related dynamic
role playing. So, you never said that like you're a little girl
and you never expressed that you were 15, but you like wore little
girls' clothes and you also like had a [__] baby
in your mouth, but it was never expressed through age-related
dynamic role playing. You weren't like pretending to be a baby
or something. Given the fact that Aiden's initial statement here
is Larex confided in me like 2 years ago at this point that Kai
likes to pretend to be a little girl during sex and did this
with Tom.
Yep. Yeah, Kai groomed Tom. What age play have we actually got
evidence that Tom's engaged with the with the other girls? Cuz
I haven't heard anything about him and anybody else. He has a
sexual attraction to really to like small boobs, smaller boobs,
smaller like bodies, this kind of thing. Like he's He's got like
a sexual attraction to children from Game of Thrones. He said
that [__] about the kids from Game of Thrones. He
was like, "You're like the the elf from Game of Thrones or whatever."
Yeah, somebody sent me a [__] picture of that. The
dude is adorable. Dude, wait. The children There's no way he
said you're like the children of the forest. I think that's what
he was saying. That's what he was saying. He said, "You're like
the elf girl from Game of Thrones." That's what he said. "You're
like so petite. You're like the elf girl from Game of Thrones."
He could mean Daenerys, some people said, but Daenerys isn't
like an elf, right? Lock this up. Lock this up right now.
They're literally the children of the forest, by the way. They're
literally called the children of the forest, by the way. Like
the whole point of them is they look like children.
The whole point is they look like just To be clear, that's that's
why they call them the children of the forest. They're like not
children, right? I think they're thousand-year-old beings, okay?
That's how it works for people. Okay, Tom. Tom, we can get you
out of this one. This is my ideal thing. This is my thing. I'm
still I'm just Yeah. I'm still shocked that you like my boobs.
What the hell [__] [__] like the [__]
elf girl from Game of Thrones would be like? So true. Oh my god.
Well, I imagine the elf girl from Game of Thrones would be like
like any Is that not Does it seem like you're talking about Daenerys?
Why would this elf girl be so distinct from anyone else? I 100%
think he means Daenerys, but if you guys want to [__]
around, I I think it's funny. You really think he means Daenerys?
I 100% I I think he means Daenerys. Now, I think he means I'll
be very clear again. I think he means Daenerys when she's like
canonically 14 and probably even in the show fairly young, where
she does look like a child. Like that is the whole point. Oh,
that's the whole point. If she If she doesn't really look like
a [__] child, really. She's an adult. It's an adult.
She's not saying that like she's a child in the same way as [__]
you know. They're saying they're trying to make her look young.
They're emphasizing all the innocence and stuff when she's They
all make her look young in the show, yes, but you know, you can
tell the actress isn't, you know, and you're going to be just
be thinking of the [__] actress.
Okay, I'm just saying I I I can't imagine like attaching any
kind of like
aspect to these [__] guys at all.
Like they look more like treants. Okay, the other one Jace will
showed actually looks like a human.
The kid.
Yes, that's what I think he's saying. That's what he That's what
I think he's saying. Hold on. Hold on. I do have to come back
for just a second. Yes, one children of the forest. Cuz I'm going
to go ahead and show you, unfortunately,
unfortunately for everybody, okay? This is I'm sorry. Wait. Wait.
I'm sorry. Here are my thoughts. Now, can we go look up the creepy
hoarder pictures real quick and see if you Is this the first
time Have you not been online before? Have you Have you just
got the internet today? But I can't imagine anyone attaching
imagery to these tree people,
Really. I think that's way out there, dude. You get splinters
on your dick. Dude, no, it's not. Okay. You're [__]
like And now you're saying stupid [__] to me like
you get splinters on your dick. Yeah, that's what people are
thinking about when they think about fictional characters, isn't
it? It's the specific mechanics of how it might work. Oh, yeah,
you'll get splinters on your I can't possibly be attracted to
that.
I can't imagine people attaching like aspects to dogs, okay?
To cats, to elephants, to birds, to dinosaurs, to plants.
That's a category error. There's no [__] way that
Poison Ivy. Poison Ivy. Dickers, Dickers, I have a I have a fantastic
question for you. Do you think this face would be totally
Do you think it would fit normally on whatever this person's
face would be?
You don't think this face could fit normally totally with this?
I feel like you're I feel like you're asking me to like photo
like Photoshop a [__] child's face onto a [__]
picture of a tree right now in my mind. I don't want to [__]
think about that. This is not What do you mean I feel like I
feel like you're asking me to like think about this. But unfortunately,
I think the evidence is that it is the woman that Tom tried to
get You should be careful. Be careful. He told me to stop.
Very interesting uh discussion you guys are having here. Okay,
I Now we're all going to be uncomfortable.
Kenny, speak your [__] What do you think of this
girl? Kenny, what do you think of this girl?
All right. I I just observe everything happening. You know, I
You know, it's all it's It's comedy. I I do this for fun, but
you know, it was [__] up.
But show me again. What What am I What am I deliberating on?
So, Dickers can't possibly imagine anyone anyone online, any
Turkey Tom type person being attracted to a tree character. Okay,
character that's like part tree.
What do you think of it, Kenny?
You think that's totally out of the realm of possibility? You
might get splinters on your dick. I think Dickers needs to shed
his skin and just like accept accept being a freak. Dickers,
you decided this when you signed up for this um job, so yeah.
it's very normal, man. Like these guys, you know, Jace and Queen
and they scrolled 4chan. They were definitely like relishing
in this back in the day. These guys Okay. And these guys are
watching Game of Thrones. They love
I've refined it, okay? I've figured out the difference between
these people, all right, and Poison Ivy. Poison Ivy's depicted
with like luscious vines and like soft soft leaves. Like that's
the closest that you can get to like human flesh or like You
know, there is like endless endless There's no way that you're
going to pick up a leaf and moss.
What are we saying here, dude? This is
the most I've ever heard. It must be your first week online.
That's the only conclusion I can come to for us. Either that
or you're like He's playing dumb. He obviously knows what 3 +
Anything. Yeah, exactly. But if it
it's like it's got to be like 0.1% for me. I don't know. He's
got to be talking about somebody else. I cannot believe he's
talking about the [__] moss
I mean, you can You can find it in yourself if there is some
world where you're attracted to the [__] moss
What's the point?
I MEAN, WHAT ARE THE ODDS TO BE BOTH A AND INTO MOSS?
Uh wait. Hold on. No, no, no. This is This is the This is the
safe pick. This is the child that is the thousand-year-old demon.
Wait. Wait. Wait. This is the safe pick. This is the child that
is the thousand-year-old demon. That's why the I did that. That's
what it it, okay? It's just like the anime people. Right? This
is the This is the person who's Yeah, this person's thousands
of years old.
Listen, I'm not saying all this for >> grow up into adult
versions where?
Are these the adult versions?
But they're all scaly and stuff.
Dude, this picture is particularly
Which is like bent it over.
Yeah, I just like yeah,
There is really nothing behind is there?
No. No, there's nothing.
But that's what he's talking about. He's saying are you flat
and petite?
No, but like small >> I will point out I will point out
Daenerys is Daenerys is flat and petite. Daenerys looks like
a child.
That's why they cast her. Why are you trying to say that Daenerys
looks like a child? Yeah, she looks like a child like the lead
actor of Tokyo Drift looks like a child, dude. Like it's just
not like a child. She's like
I don't think that anybody could possibly into be flat asses.
That's the problem with me.
That's the problem right now. I think that I can understand if
Turkey Tom or like people are into like small I get that. I don't
think I've ever heard of anybody being into flat asses.
That's just not capable in like male I don't think.
No? Tom is 100% into that. What do you
Well, like no ass, like a plank of wood.
Yeah. That's the preference.
Okay. Um I mean that's downstream of everything else he's described.
Yes.
It's quite literally downstream of everything else. >> I
don't I don't I don't want to describe this. I don't want I don't
want to go too in-depth on this topic with the [__]
like wood child on the [__]
Oh my god.
Are you worried about your optics right
No, no, no, no. It's just like this is a shame of my vision having
that in my eye view I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I can do that. This woman's an adult. This woman's an adult,
okay? I can be interested in like
all right? Looking at this, Dickers Dickers gets hard. TRYING
TO IMAGINE THIS FACE ON this photo, Dickers does not get hard.
This is This is evil. Imagining this face on this photo, that's
totally wrong.
But this photo alone, yeah, W W W, let's >> It's just cuz
in my mind I know that she's an adult, okay? I know that she's
>> Right, right. That's That's how it works, isn't it?
That's how it works. I'm positive that's what Turkey Tom told
himself. Yep. Well, she's tall enough. She's tall enough to be
an adult.
Oh, so now it's tall. Now tight. What? Now it's tight. This guy.
You're going to get locked up, bro. You need to
Listen, I'm Better than the Go go go back to the [__]
tree tree girl.
Uh this one? Yeah, I feel like these are worlds apart, no?
Everything here is trying to look like a 12-year-old. I can't
tell you like if you got asked what the age was of this girl,
if she didn't have a phone, if somebody's taking a picture of
her, you had asked what the age of this girl was, I feel like
you could easily say like
But maybe 14. 12?
Listen, I think that's sick. I'm I'm pretty far I'm pretty far
out of the realm of considering that. 14, 15, you can actually
say 14, 15.
I would take 16.
Which is legal in the United Kingdom. I hate you. I think you
should be in prison. Stop talking about how much you want to
[__] this girl. It's actually weirding me out now,
okay? Jesus Christ.
Listen, okay, I'm just saying that I can imagine Turkey Tom looking
at this girl and imagine that she has a shapely ass,
I don't think that I don't think that Tom would be interested
if he thinks there's like nothing there. >> Dickers. Jail
Dickers.
Tell me I'm wrong. Tell me I'm wrong. This is You You think you'd
look at this and you're like this girl definitely has a big ass.
You look at
Look at these legs with no fat on them at all. You look at these
totally skinny legs. You go no no muscle, no fat. You go yeah,
she's going to have a huge ass.
For sure. I didn't say that. I didn't say that. I said shapely.
Yeah, shapely as in all right angles.
Literally nothing but right angles. Shapely as in like you know,
round. It's got some like It's got curve to it. >> like
an anatomical model of a skeleton.
Yeah, I'm thinking about it. No, this guy is clearly clearly
into ED stuff. Yeah, probably not. Probably not then. Never mind.
Yeah, I completely I'm sorry, he is I mean
Yeah. I just want to I just want to engage in saying that she
has hips. Yeah, okay, I'm back on it now. I'm back on it now.
She's got hips. Shapely ass.
Does she Does she have hips? I'm trying to Dude, this photo unfortunately
would give it all away. But for some This photo is censored.
Hold on. Looking looking looking
Such hips. >> What is this? >> Such hips. Wow, amazing
hips.
Damn. Damn.
Duh.
Yeah, it's 16 at the youngest, he says. chemically castrated
16 at the youngest.
Dickers, you've seen these images before. You know what You know
what you're sweeping for. I know you've seen these images before.
This is not the first time we're showing these to you.
Yeah, but I'm like a I'm a I'm like a
So, like I've tried to like scrub these images from my mind.
Right. Is it Is it Is it so not Is actually like a reverse
Every image in my mind that could possibly be a lewd image of
a child instantly wiped.
You guys seem to have intimate knowledge about these images though.
You guys been doing a lot of lot of research, lot of prep before
stream? What's going on there? I literally stream. I've streamed
like 40 hours in the past like 5 days.
But haven't you? You've gone through this stuff.
This is By the way, this is critical.
This is Okay, well, maybe you should opt out of the Turkey Tom
question cuz here there There'd be questions, okay? You got to
You got to figure some [__] out
You can't be the guy who's blind to any child, okay? And then
be the guy trying to figure out whether or not Turkey Tom's a
people.
Look, I don't I don't want to dip one toe into the pond. I'll
let you guys swim in it. You seem super comfortable. You This
This seems like your place. This seems like your topic.
This is definitely not Dickers' topic.
This is shameful.
This has gone terribly.
I I'll be I was seeing Dickers in my head. I When I had private
conversations with Queen Man, I'm like you're too hard on Dickers.
You're too hard on Dickers. And I feel like this conversation's
earned his greeting to you when he first met you in the UK.
That is now deserved.
I was defending par for the course yesterday. I had a whole argument
for Yeah, we had an all out argument about par for the course.
>> Regret it.
I've gone back on par for the course, by the way. Which I Which
I won, by the way. Yeah, you you you lost. You lost. You went
back on it.
No, I've I've gone back on Oh, now now you realize it. I did
this in the moment, okay? On the fly.
So, I just thought it wasn't that important. Can you Can you
say what you said to Dickers? Let's hear your quote.
No, I don't I don't know.
It's about what you're saying. So, it Impossible what you were
saying is still cringe anyway. We need the clip. We need the
clip. We need to hear what Dickers said. Exactly from the beginning
to end. We absolutely need the clip. If we're going to argue
this, everyone needs to see the clip before we argue
Go for it. Because you you say essentially you say I think this
girl is just This girl is
Okay? She's saying she bleeds like most of the times basically
is what she's
She bleeds regularly
And she says that Tom bent just would just bend her over and
start obviously saying what No, no, no, no. That's far later
in the document. That's far later in the document. And Dickers
says
Well, clearly this girl is just very inexperienced. She doesn't
realize that it's par for the course to bleed when you're having
rough That's what Dickers said.
What I was talking about is directly after the three times in
one day DM. That's what I was reading afterwards.
I don't believe you that all this all this stuff came after and
I thought
We need We're going to need to see the doc and see what information
you had at the time because I don't believe you that all that
stuff comes after. I'm pretty sure a lot of that stuff came
Sure. So, you need something else Pull the clip up. Pull the
clip up. We need the clip.
There it is.
This is not going to give us all of >> What she's saying
is that she's had extremely normal vanilla before, has not engaged
in these dynamics, goes to try them out, doesn't know what to
expect. Cuz I'm going to be honest. if you haven't watched that
clip before >> pause, pause, pause, pause. You just read
a crazy amount in there either way. You just read a crazy amount
in and you just saw woman describing bleeding after sex and you're
like, "Oh, you see, this is this is an unexperienced woman, you
know? She just doesn't understand the kink scene, does she? She
doesn't understand you part for the course you Anyway, It's a
read. It's a read.
It's a read.
I do think the I do think it was the bad read. My read on this
with the same document, same information was, yeah, Turkey Tom
going in dry. Turkey Tom don't know what foreplay is. Just pointed
out, okay? That's the normal
I don't know where this read came from.
Letting you know. Okay, get playing the clip. Let's let's hear
more. A little bit of bleeding
is kind of par for the course. It's the most common cause of
bleeding. No? Rough prolonged sex. I It's just Okay.
So, I mean, I think that there's there's some truth to that.
There's some there's some truth to that, but yes, sex is a pretty
common cause and it doesn't necessarily mean that anything crazy
wrong has happened.
But I thought this this is like a this is a jump. >> sex.
Not sex, full stop, right? >> Well, but it's either rough,
prolonged, or without, you know, lubrication, foreplay, whatever.
Right? So.
But this is a crazy read. This was like a you were jumping. You
were jumping. You jumped like three steps here.
And then you said par for the course. And what is just say let's
say your defense of par for the course. So, you're saying
The course A golf course has got lots of holes, right? Yep. You
don't just You don't just putt one hole and then that's like
you done, you know? That's like several times. You're You're
putting several times, right? So, how many times is Tom putting?
What? No, no, no, no. You say So, this is what you say. >> with
these dynamics. I know what you're trying to say. I know what
you're trying to say. I'm engaging with these dynamics. Right,
okay. Go on. You You're saying So, all you've got here
is that this girl
has said that she's bled after sex.
Uh after having sex three times.
And you're saying yeah, if you're having rough sex three times
engaging in these dynamics,
then it's par for the course to bleed.
That's what you're saying.
That's not par for the course. It's not to be expected. That's
what par for the course means. It's not to be expected. >> Or
not from doing it absolutely unexpected. I'm saying if you're
engaging that
Yeah, yeah, it's not unexpected. It's not like, "Wow, this is
the craziest thing that's ever happened." This is But it's not
to be expected. You don't go into that thinking this is going
to
>> No, no, no, it's not that it's going to happen. I think
after this clip, I used the term assumption of risk.
Okay, we're talking about this clip. So, I get what you're saying.
Wait, where'd this clip come from, by the way? I don't know.
I think this clip comes from Kiwi Farms. You really sourcing
your information from Kiwi Farms? I am, yeah. Yeah, all the time.
Anything's justified against
Dishonest Dishonest narratives.
That's a gossip forum, you know?
Jesus Christ, man. >> That's loud. That's loud.
I'm a little bit out of the weather. Holy [__]
Dickers, What is happening? I'm a little bit out of the weather
if you could probably tell, but Dickers, everybody wants to know
why are you pretending like you're some Christian Christian What's
the guy name? Christian Grey harsh BDSM master?
That's what everyone's asking. They're all beating around the
bush and we're tired of it, quite frankly, us chatters. We want
to know how often you are spanking your girlfriend's
with a leather leather strap, Dickers. We want to know. We all
have to know. >> of your BDSM gear right now. Show us the
Come on stream. If you don't come on stream with some fuzzy handcuffs
next stream, we're going to have to >> We both I can't
say it's Jstock's stream. I don't want to disrespect Jstock's
stream. But you know what we're going to have to do, Dickers?
That's all I'm saying. Aiden knows where you live and Aiden he'll
squeal like a pig. That's all I'm saying.
That's true.
Answer the question.
What's your What's life like, Dickers? How How often are you
paddling your
with a leather strap? How often is it happening? Dude, there's
no way he's on here voice cracking like this. >> I'm not
I'm not answering this question.
How about you, Stahli?
>> I'm not I'm not pretending I'm on I'm not on my stream
>> What No, no, no, no, no. What are you trying to pretend?
What What's going on? What's happening?
>> 50 shades of 50 shades of beating is what I'm saying.
How many shades How many >> like iron cross or whatever
it is in in my basement. >> can sell this right now. Dickers
just cams up and shows us the gear he's got.
You should have like a briefcase or something, surely, since
you you seem very knowledgeable on the topic. That's how you're
presenting yourself on >> one paddle. I just want one paddle.
You guys are going crazy, okay? I can't even afford a backdrop.
You think I could afford paddles?
Okay. But see, HE THINKS IT'S YOUR HOBBY. He seems very knowledgeable.
That's what I'm saying.
Cuz like you don't know about golf and that's like a very popular
sport. So, I'm assuming you allocated the time >> is a
sport. It's an extremely popular It's an internationally popular
sport, quite frankly. So, what I'm saying >> sport in your
country, by the way. You Yeah, that's what I'm saying. Masters?
What do you All right, bro.
You've lost all of your knowledge of popular popular popular
sports >> I know Listen, I and you've transferred it to
BDSM
and I I'd like to know what you have to say.
I'm saying you're thinking of me, Christian Grey. I do not have
the class to be able to go golfing. I've never been golfing in
my life.
But you have been a harsh daddy BDSM
What's the Is this conversation? I feel like I'm high right now.
You You do understand that you have quite literally pushed in
that direction and and like intimated that multiple times, right?
I have no
I don't know why you're feigning incredulity right now when you
were you were totally trying to come across as like very knowledgeable.
That's what I'm saying.
we watch we watch that Me and Queenie will watch your conversation
with Morality where you're like making the faces and stuff. You're
You're definitely
sample size. You are going hard on this guy. Yeah, that's cuz
my sample size is of one. >> No, no, no. You You said It
wasn't about the sample size. It was when you were
You were saying You You're having You're the same person I argue
with every time this topic comes up. You're having the most tepid,
scared scared to thrust too hard sex ever. Oh, you you you even
made fun of his voice. You're like, "Oh, is that too hard, darling?"
That's what you WERE DOING, BRO.
YOU DID You did a voice. That was [__]
You made it sound like he was like a
who would only been in one position in his entire life.
Well, that's what he says.
That's what he says.
>> And we'd like to know how many have you been paddling
with a leather strap? We'd like to know. We just want to know.
How many times have you tied a woman to a bed post and paddled
her [__]
with a leather strap? We'd like to know.
I don't even know how to answer this question, bro. >> What
if I pick a number from from zero?
Zero I'm just saying starting at zero. I'm not applying anything
to like a
you know? You only have so much time. What are you, like 28?
We can We can start with greater than zero. Maybe that's greater
than zero.
I'm I'm not answering. I'm not >> Is it bigger than five?
Should we go high low? Can we high low this?
All right. Jstock, you say a number >> The answer is undefined.
The answer is undefined. So, I'm just saying like like a vertical
line? >> You've engaged in You've engaged in some BDSM
[__] right?
You've You've represented yourself as somebody who's engaged
in this stuff. Well, yeah, you represented yourself that way.
That's how you came across in the conversation.
When did I talk about paddling with Morality? Hold on. You're
trying to be That's very weaselly. That's why I went way more
broad.
I'm using it as an example. >> more broad. We all understand
what the conversation is about, Dickers. You can't slip away
from this.
The conversation about
We're not talking about [__] paddling. We're not
talking about No, you were talking about We're not talking about
[__] handcuffs. too scared to thrust too hard in
a woman.
>> it was in the context Okay. I just I'm going to I'm
going to sign >> a harsh BDSM daddy master. I'm going to
I'm going to I'm going to sign shark real quick. Do you feel
as though Morality would be the kind of person who would give
confident thrusts?
What is this I want to make sure I want to make sure that you're
being honest in this conversation. What is this dodging deflection
question?
No, no, you're asking me questions you haven't answered a single
question this entire time. I'm posing myself with Morality, right?
And I agree. I agree. >> You were You were just
I'm going to go to that in a little bit, Jack. Do you think that
Marou, you seem very very scared to answer this question. Do
you think Marou would be the kind of person to put kind of person
to give confident thrusts? I don't know what Marou's life is
like. The last time I know he was like talking to a 17-year-old.
I don't really know what's going on over Several several years
ago he had sex with one woman three times.
How do you know this much about Marou? What the hell is going
on? He said it in that conversation. He said it in the
I know something that not a lot of other people know, okay? And
I pointed this out to Queeman.
You kind of gave away that you don't do any C&C stuff at
all.
Right? Would you you agree with that,
Are you just going to you're just going to not respond? You won't
you won't respond in the affirmative? You won't respond in the
negative? This is so weird. You're such a freak.
I I refuse I refuse to answer any of these questions. I'm I'm
remaining
politic on all of these questions.
I I feel like you went in on Marou because he was a virgin and
you styled on him and now when we're like, "Hey, we're checking
your bonafides here." You're you're opting out of the the
with more than one woman.
That's the bonafide.
That's the only bonafides THAT I NEED TO HAVE that kind of conversation
with
Hold on. Oh, you're getting saved right now. It doesn't appear
there's a transcript on your stream. when women walk funny the
day after
That was that was obviously like a joke. That was like a joke.
Obviously that was like a joke when he said that.
Mhm. Haven't spoken to Marou as much as I have.
Oh boy, I
I really got to find the clip and now I can't cuz there's there's
no transcript on your stream. But there's a point where you're
talking about like you know when you hold a woman down you just
like thrust super hard into her that's when bleeding occurs,
right? When you're engaging in It's you say it this way. You
engage it you say it this way. When you're engaging in C&C
dynamics and you're like pounding a girl as hard as possible
that's the most likely time you get
>> no. I said if No. Wait. Wait. What do you mean?
Okay. Wait. Wait. Wait. You might have said if but you realize
that's not true, >> We we was talking we was talking still
in the context of the Turkey Tom
Well, how would you know those? What were asking?
What's is more vigorous the night is basically the foundation
for the
Well, I mean Jason's got an argument here I believe. Jason's
got an argument
You you do not you're because the the we can agree that the way
people bleed is the in and out like the actual back and forth
right the friction causes micro tears, yeah?
Okay. So when you're engaging in C&C
you're holding somebody down you got other [__] going
on. You can't just focus on thrusting as hard as you can, okay?
You're you got a whole bunch of other So you're just like gave
it away that you didn't actually engage in the C&C stuff,
okay?
Wait. What are you what are you what are you talking You got
other stuff going
Yeah, you're holding somebody down. You can't focus on thrusting.
You don't have all of your energy going into thrusting. You are
literally holding somebody down.
You think you can thrust full force while you're holding a woman
down? I don't know. I don't I I don't know.
This guy's totally willing to have this conversation with Marou
and now he's opting out of it entirely. He's actually like defend
my own I to be clear. Defend my own I to I can't talk about this.
I can't talk about I can't talk about this. I can't talk about
this. I can't talk about Bro, what can you talk about?
What are you good to talk about?
Oh yeah, Dickers. You're like a out of it as well. I forgot I
I forgot that's why I called in in the beginning with. Dickers
Dickers, that little girl that that Jason talked about up had
like from her from her like midsection all the way down was like
a straight drop and you're talking about her shapely ass. What
is your problem, bro? Listen, okay? Can we go back Can we go
back to that? The better of you being a
NO NO NO.
WAIT. CAN WE GO BACK TO THAT IMAGE?
YEAH, WE CAN GO BACK TO THIS IMAGE. The way the SKIRT
YEAH. YEAH.
THE WAY THE SKIRT falls over the pants. I believe is to give
the illusion of hips and the illusion of a shapely ass. Now we
know that that is merely an illusion now.
We know that's merely an illusion now. But the way We knew the
Wait. Listen. We knew the whole time. You however
was very confident that this woman had a shapely ass. In your
opinion, would you say these are breeding hips, Dickers? Is that
what you Is that what you describe these I didn't say all that.
Okay. I
Dickers, is this the kind of woman you'd be battling the the
the with the leather
Is this what you Is this how you was getting down
in your little harsh BDSM master clubs?
Well, I can
Waiting. HE'S THINKING.
IF IF I HOLD ON. OKAY. CUZ IF I if I if I say no
I accept the premise of the question
which I've already refused to answer.
But if I refuse to answer
I I look like a
Wait. Dickers Dickers. I will say that she is the kind of woman
that I'm interested in.
And on the question of on the of Dickers sexual dynamics I refuse
to answer.
Dickers, have you ever [__] a dog? Have you ever
[__] a dog, Dickers?
Oh, there you go. That's that's the kind of answer we're looking
for. All right.
What's this guy's [__] problem, man?
Uh okay.
We're having a great time, guys. We're having a great time.
We can pull that Marou conversation up. Dickers, what it would
be like to child feels like in a Roblox server. Holy
Yeah, let's uh let's review this Marou conversation. Let's uh
analyze this with Dickers here. Where does it Where does this
Marou conversation start? >> Talking about how he's how
he's displaying himself as a Christian Grey BDSM Dickers Dickers
Dickers content released. Does that make sense? That's why I'm
saying he's right
So he's hitting her from behind and he's putting her his his
hand over Oh, hold on. Hold on. Little too little too early?
I think it's this part.
Right here. Okay. Get your right hand and put it around your
mouth like you're holding your mouth shut.
See where your thumb is on your face?
That's where her nose is. Does that make sense? That's why I'm
saying he's right
So he's hitting her from behind and he's putting her his his
hand over her mouth and that's that's why you're saying he's
right handed. She claims two things. She claims he either punched
her
which I don't know why she gives two solutions for this. She's
[__] But she claims she he either one punches her
in the face or two is holding her mouth shut while her from behind
and he's digging her thumb into her face, right? I think if either
one of those, you know, the other one seems more realistic. The
hand over the mouth digging thumb into your face. He's like squeezing
her face kind of. I think that's probably what what happened
because like if you I don't know if you've ever been in a fight.
If you get punched in the face it's not like a little dot like
that. By the way, this is 100% what did
Like a a big oval shape Like sorry. We We have confirmation from
Null that that is exactly what she said. Like egg-shaped bruise
rather than like a little dot. I can imagine like pinching someone.
I've been pinched before. Like that kind of or like press or
like bump your head on something. Like maybe she bumped her face
on the bed frame or something like that. But yeah, I don't know.
She was definitely not punched. That's not a punch bruise.
Well, the I mean the difference would be that this is like not
a fight punch where he's actually trying to like hurt her. Like
I don't think that he's like punching her and trying to test
if she's got like a glass jaw, right? It's not like a boxing
punch. It would be for like the purposes of BDSM play. So it
it might not be a like a full
But it's just something for the dynamic. something [__]
If it's from behind
Are you not What What is your knowledge of BDSM punches, Dickers?
Yeah, that would leave like tiny bruises like the size of a thumb.
I'm imagining that if you're having
with the lady and you're going to go and punch her because she
wants to consensually, you know engage in fisticuffs while having
sex that you're not going to donkey punch
Well, that's the back of the head. You should know that.
Wait. That's right. Wait. Donkey punch to the back. Okay. You're
not going to sucker punch her, right? Well, it's not a sucker
punch cuz she knows it's coming.
You'd not punch her very very hard as if you're in like a fight
with a man. >> You also won't punch her in the face.
Wait. What? You would be like slap her in the face not like punch
her. The face punches are pretty I thought that the punch was
alleged already, no?
No. Uh hitting.
Up to that point in the document hitting I believe. I thought
that I thought that they'd say slap and
Yeah, I cleared all of it last time. Did they not say slapping
and hitting? Does that not Does that not presume you're like
some kind of punch like an I don't know what would that be. I
think I think hitting refers to generally like impact play of
some kind. I don't think it I don't think it goes to punches.
Uh but it's it's not quite a slap.
What would that I don't know what that would I don't know what
that would be.
Well, I thought they said slapping and hitting. This is the word
they've used
Yeah, in that case I would imagine the slapping is on the face
and the hitting is other where or other places,
Why would you presume now?
Uh because it's the standard dynamic that like 99.9% of people
are fine with.
Now, I think I think if Turkey Tom was going like we'd be having
a totally different conversation if Turkey Tom was like literally
giving him the Mike Tyson one two with all of his like first
interactions. I think we'd be having a whole I don't think he'd
make it this far. Well, that's >> You know what I mean?
That's my Well, that's my point, right? I don't think that he's
like full on punching her.
Yeah, but I would say closed fist to the face. You're going to
have people going like that. >> a completely different
mark. Like I know what you're talking about. How's that?
Well, if you close your fist, you've got like a you'll have like
knuckles that will stick out beforehand. >> Yeah, well,
I don't I have like a normal man hand, so all my knuckles are
like in a line. So, I don't know if you have like a little homunculus
finger where your knuckles are all in a line. Your knuckles extend
really far. fist like in front of you. Wait, what? >> Yeah,
are you saying Tom has like It's a complete [__]
line. body where he can stop his one knuckle. Of course, it's
not a straight line. Okay, but >> You've got knuckles.
I think we're getting stuck on stupid, Nick. That's what is happening
here.
Anyway, I was being I was wondering punches and stuff. I was
wondering what you what you had for knowledge there. But you're
just saying you imagined it. So, wait, you can work this whole
thing back. You just say I've never done any of this stuff. I
have no experience. And you know I gave the impression even though
I gave the impression I didn't mean to give the impression. I
was just >> I'd lose the debate with Moral. I'd be conceding
ground on the debate with
Which I refuse to do.
So, I'm going to take that to And he's right-handed, the bruise
would be on the left side. No, it wouldn't. Get your right hand,
put it over your face. Where is your thumb? Your thumb is on
the right side of your face. It would be on the right side of
her face if that is what is going on. Yeah.
Um yeah. >> I It looks like unless she can unless she can
conclusively say where this bruise has come from, it is really
hard to say. Cuz you would have to be pressing on extremely hard
for your thumb to create a bruise.
That seems very very Like I I
I don't want to be an [__] I feel like
you got so many things wrong in the reads here that that's the
direction I'm going is that she just really haven't engaged with
this stuff at all.
Like I'm making that allegation cuz cuz the thumb thing is like
objectively what she's saying happened. Like she came out and
told Noll that and she sent a picture of that and saying that's
how I got the bruise.
And that's what I said before I even watched this Moral thing
that that's how she got the bruise. I just feel like yeah.
That's that's what I'm saying.
When did the thumb thing come out? This was two days ago.
Um just today. I think Noll or maybe this morning, last night,
one of the two. Noll released like some message
Yeah, he said he got message like a picture of that. describes
this exact >> Yeah, I don't think I was aware at the
Or at least I didn't know you. >> Yeah, no. No. That's
why I'm saying that like based on this read, I was like, oh,
it's clearly the thumb like holding the
But I I that's why I feel like you just didn't engage in this
stuff or you don't engage in this stuff very much.
That was my opinion. >> somebody's face.
That would have to Yeah, okay. I don't know I don't know >> Okay, you
would have to squeeze really hard like during rough
Yeah, good point. It's a good one. I feel like your your hand
would cramp before you'd ever bruise them. Okay, dude.
It's like a meter. There's two meters going on. You have to balance
them. Wait, you know that like grabbing somebody's wrist like
women get bruised just from grabbing their wrist too hard. Women
get bruised like all the time from [__] like that.
>> Especially when they're like 95 lbs and look like little
girls.
Yeah. You guys thought about the sticker >> outside. I
mean like a harsh waiter. eating disorders.
Am I getting the understanding that the women you're a harsh
BDSM daddy dom master for are like very overweight and they can
like take a hit or two? Is that what I'm getting?
Well, you you put stuff in in boxing boxing uh What are they
called? Gloves?
No, the uh the punch bags. Oh, the the punching
That's the one. It's not a sandbag. What the [__]
is it called?
Never mind. [__] it. [__] it. [__]
it. >> So, you don't know golf. You don't know
But you do know harsh BDSM daddy mastering. That's what I'm hearing.
I've been I've been I I remained I remained silent on that.
Nick, there's what do you know? >> with the video?
Nick is God, okay? He's a man of the He's a man of the cloth?
Is that what they say?
Right? If you guys say it right?
A man of the tablecloth by the side of
Okay, I'm sorry. You Am I really the only one laughing at that?
That was awesome. Okay, whatever,
>> It's possible.
it's possible. Unless she wants to come out and make like a more
I'm going to take a break right now. Midg Magic, get your hand,
PUT IT ON YOUR MOUTH. WHERE IS YOUR THUMB? GET YOUR RIGHT HAND,
OKAY? Your right hand. If you're on a computer right now, okay?
The date and time, right side of your computer. I don't know
if you got your left and right make stop.
Get your right hand, PUT IT OVER YOUR MOUTH. WHERE'S YOUR THUMB?
ANYWAY, SORRY. You were saying? Yeah. Uh unless she wants to
come out and make like like a stronger claim about the how that
happened.
Um yeah, I'm not sure. I'm not even sure what what exact purpose
this has for what this exact like proves. Like what's the difference?
If she did this to a She calls Tom a predator. This is This is
what she's trying to substantiate. Katie directly calls Tom a
predator for what he did to her. He calls him a predator. So,
I would assume in her mind this is what this is proving. It's
predation or like abuse.
I think it'd be aggression. I don't think this proves predation.
Like predation would speak to how he's picking these girls.
Uh well, I agree with you, but I don't like I from how from her
perspective, I think that's what she's trying to prove. She's
like, he's a predator. Let me provide evidence that he abused
me,
Maybe I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. That that's that's
my read of it. That's my read. To me, this is her evidence trying
to prove that he's a predator, but that's that's just my read.
I don't know. I think if he's saying to the Sacramento girl that
he's not interested in the BPD girls anymore. Well, presumably
that would be his type, right? Going after the BPD girls, which
maybe she sees as predatory. Um which yeah, I'm not sure. I'm
not sure. Um I don't think that when she's like talking about
her face bruise though that that falls in line with predatory
unless she's like completely misunderstood what that word means.
But yeah, at that point, I mean, I don't know how you can like
interpret anybody's statements ever. If you're just kind of assuming
Are all Sanrio girls BPD? Not necessarily. I'd never make that
claim, but I will say all Sanrio girls are likely into some form
of age play, okay? That is another part of the Kai document that
we do a little slight of hand. Oh, Tom's just into Sanrio girls.
Wait, girls who like like toys made for 10-year-old girls? Like
those Okay, I'm >> they might not understand how what this
word means.
Um Yeah, but that's what I mean. You can
It but it at that point, you're just going to have to accept
that like you are going to have to like question and quibble
over the definitions of every single word Change my mind. She's
average intelligence. You're right. If you're not seen that,
it's not below average. Katie did?
Yeah, if you're not seen that,
Why did she call you a What did you do? Um so, I gave the take
that before realizing that it had gone on for three days, okay?
Before realizing this was something that both girls had experience,
okay? When she's talking about bleeding during I say that in
and of itself,
that isn't actually that indicative of abuse cuz that can happen
if you're three times in one day and you're engaging in rough
sex. And so, the fact that she finds this notable is just because
she's had vanilla before then he's going with Tom having three
times in one day, very aggressive sex, right?
That was the take.
Okay, can we just Can we pause there? That's insane self-sweeping
there. Crazy
I'm giving her I'm giving her more full definition or more full
explanation of what I was saying outside >> about what
happened in the clip. She called you a She did bombs. She Yeah,
that's the clip she was replying to. That's why she called you
a
That's what That's what Moral was asking you about.
Yeah, but I'm saying about the take that I gave.
Yeah, but Moral was asking you why you would say that. You didn't
ask. >> What what we were looking for what we were looking
for there is where >> it sound Yeah, but what I'm saying
is you make it sound like totally insane that anyone would anyone
would say something like that about you. In a in a more full
clip, yeah. In a more full clip.
She didn't see the more full clip.
She didn't, but I'm just explaining what I said to Maral. Yeah,
but like I said, he's asking you why you would say that in the
video clip. >> be explaining that you got clip chimped
Yeah, you should be like, you know, Oh, yeah, I said I you know,
I said it was par for the course to bleed during
I think I think I'm explaining there the context that I didn't
have yet. So, presumably Maral already knows that I'm explaining
the wider context of this and not necessarily the exact like
30-second clip, right?
Like I'm not pretending to say what I said in that 30-second
clip. You won't be able to get the information that I gave there
from a 30-second clip. >> But Maral doesn't know about
this. Maral doesn't know what's going on.
Well, no, but okay. You're acting as I'm being dishonest about
the take that I gave. That's not true. Everything I'm saying
there implies that I'm giving more full context.
That doesn't. Why why do you say you're giving more full context?
>> we're just talking past each other. I think um what
I've been saying Maral's asking why this happened. You're not
really saying why it happened. You're just giving your take.
Which is sort of dis unintentionally
I'll be sure you know, unintentionally dishonest. Um I think
I'm being honest about the fact that I'm giving more wider context,
but fine.
Okay. Well, hold on. Maybe I'll roll >> happening if you're
having sex three times in one day before realizing this was something
that Wait, wait, wait. So, it's she called me a He says, wait,
did that really happen? What happened? You're laughing. called
you a What did you do? Um so, I gave the take that before realizing
that it had gone on for three days, okay? Before realizing this
was something that both girls had experience, okay? When she's
talking about bleeding during sex, I say that in and of itself
that isn't actually that indicative of abuse cuz that can happen
if you're having sex three times in one
Yeah, but I'm press it I'm prefacing with this with the fact
that I'm giving more full context. So, obviously I'm giving my
more full context. >> before Sorry, the full context you're
giving you're saying before realizing X, before realizing Y.
Then you say, I said or I gave a take that and then you go in
to describe what your take was. But when you describe what your
take was, you're not using the words you used before. But I'm
just I'm describing the take, not the clip.
Yeah, but
you're being asked why this happened and and so you've already
given the wider context. So, why not just say what you said?
No, you're giving like a new a new sanitized version of it. You're
being asked, why did this happen? >> just tipped $5 on
the Oh, look, it's
And no longer sweeps. >> Not necessarily what I'm talking
about. join my streams. Zip zip The II brace and Mchan doesn't
in my apartment.
Uh I did, yeah. The correct answer was I got clip
Clip chimped. Yeah.
Yo, yo, I'm I'm deep my friend now.
It's so what why have you not I just don't understand why you
don't recount like what you said, you know, you know you said.
You know exactly what you said.
But you give like this totally different version of it. Yeah.
Uh I don't remember the wording that I gave in the clip.
No, you remember you remember the wording in the clip. You remember
you said par for I'm going to I'm going to help Dickers out so
it's not just a total gangbang of Dickers the whole stream. There
could be It's not that big a deal that you didn't say it this
way. You just like, oh, I got clip chimped. Like that's that's
what happened. And I I maybe could have been more clear in the
beginning. It's like not even a big deal. Just so you know, you
could just you could just agree. I'm not saying I'm not saying
so much as you know, what I'm saying is it seems like Dickers
is trying to save face here. It seems like there is something
It's not a big deal. It seems like there is something happening
here. But it's like Maral's pressing him about this or Maral's
also pressing him about it the story's come up and and this is
now presenting it in a way where if you don't go and look at,
you know, what what he said originally, you won't you'll come
away thinking, What was anyone even What was anyone even mad
about? What was anyone even saying he was a for?
That That person who called him a is totally insane. What a insane
mentally
No. No, no, I already agree with that. But I'm happy to present
that. >> here actually. Yeah, yeah, we when you chill out,
bro. Oh, no, sorry, that's me giving Dickers mindset. It's like
what he's projecting. It's what he's making this out >> I
I'm agreeing with that. Obviously. That's the mindset of a evil
is what I'm hearing. True. I'm not not be given like the textual
history, but I've given like the spiritual history, you know?
I'm showing like the characters or like the true soul of the
characters involved.
It's the power of somebody who's been to the seminary. Let's
go.
All right.
Okay. on day and you're engaging in rough sex. And so, the fact
that she finds this notable is just because she's had vanilla
sex before, then is going with Tom having sex three times in
one day, very aggressive sex,
That was the take. Very aggressive sex. I've I've never um
I've never had a bleed on me before. Um so, I would say I don't
know. But I've also never had sex three times in a day. Let me
say let me let me just say Maral, okay?
Before Before I say this Yeah. we're friends. I like you. We're
fine. However, you are the exact same
that I talk to every time that I let you get this topic, dude.
What is your sample size?
Mhm. I will have
I feel like
Look at the face.
I know his sample size.
That's actually the worst part of this clip. I knew the sample
size I knew I knew the sample size going into it. The worst part
of the clip is where you're lying about being a harsh BDSM master.
Okay, okay, dude. The fact that Maral thinks that the bleeding
is happening during
Is that not Is that not notable to anyone else?
Um well, I mean functionally the bleeding is happening happening
during sex she's unaware of it. What are we talking about? Like
definitionally the bleeding is happening during sex. He's not
aware of it.
The abrasions come from the sex. But it's not like she's literally
leaking blood out of her during
Okay, Dickers.
Oh, no. What do you think is happening in a like in that scenario?
Do you think it's like waiting? Like it's patiently waiting until
the day is out and like maybe a couple minutes after to start
bleeding? What do you mean?
Well, cuz he's A HE PUTS ON THE BRO LIKE what In your mind, what
do you think is happening here?
Since these are micro tears and not gashes, yeah, it's not actual
blood that's coming out. It's blood mixed with
I rate it a clock in.
I think it would probably happen during. I think you would look
down and probably see like a You know the
Yeah, you'd probably see like a little Maybe it would be like
a little orange, not even like full-on red. You probably wouldn't
even see a lot, but it'd be it definitely be noticeable, I'd
feel, right? It'd be like pink in it. orange
There's a There's a reason why this is called postcoital bleeding,
Maral. Which I say to you in the conversation. >> bleeding
or did you say that? He said >> She's saying that she bled
after sex.
Mhm. She's also said that Tom's her, but you don't believe her
at that.
I don't think she used that word, did
She describes assault Dickers.
She never used the word rape.
Okay, so now okay, I see what you're doing. All right. Trying
to equivocate I'm sure I'm sure you're going to get that follow
back I'm sure you're going to get that follow back.
Also, you can point out the fact that Maral's jumped in to make
a three V one a four V one.
Bro. Yeah, but I feel like it's a little more forgivable. He's
taking a shot to get back.
Uh he's trying to get his back. >> I was unaware that we
I thought we ended that call with you conceding to me. I was
unaware that you even disagreed this whole time.
I can I conceded to Quimby on the wording par for the course.
Well, I thought I properly explained to you about the the hand
around the mouth thing. I thought that you kind of understood
what I was saying, but
Is that not what the what it started as?
That's That's what it started as, yeah. Yeah, you you were arguing
that no, it wasn't a hand around the mouth, she was punched,
right? Or am I mistaken?
Well, I'm explaining Okay, I'm explaining the moment not having
seen the thing from uh Null why I wasn't sure if that was definitive.
>> So, it took the creator of Kimi's Farms That came out
after this conversation, I think. I don't think I don't think
I think Maral was referencing Maral was referencing what what
Null had said. No, I was referencing what the girl had
It's even in this discussion what I was referencing to you. The
girl had said uh two things that happened. She said he either
punched me or he put his hand around my mouth and dug his thumb
into my face. And I was saying, okay, well, one of those is probably
more realistic. >> wording that Null was bringing in. No?
We had this discussion yesterday. I don't think no that thing
came out from Null until today.
Yeah, actually true. That only came out today. This wasn't out.
Uh So, I explained to you the girl lays out two possible scenarios
and I was like, okay, you believe the punching thing. I think
the other one's more reasonable with the size of the bruise and
like the position his hand would be
Oh, okay.
Did you concede to these guys about it? I haven't watched.
Well, I I don't think He conceded cuz the evidence is out now
of Noel saying Noel has already, yeah, given the file.
Dickers Dickers said that he thought your hand would cramp before
you could make a I believe.
He did say that just a little while ago, also. He did say that.
I did press him to say that. What?
He did say that. I stand by that. I stand by that.
Uh You stand by preschools, too, you
I mean, okay, I guess I guess my question, I'll I'll dip after
this cuz I don't want to re-tread the the [__] you
guys have already, you know, been done
Why why wasn't my explanation to you not sufficient? Why did
Why did it take Noel to convince you?
CUZ NOEL'S HAD
THAT'S THREE TIMES. NOEL'S HAD A LOT
DICKERS, DO YOU THINK NOEL HAS HAD MORE OR LESS THAN I HAVE?
YEAH, GOOD HEAD. DICKERS, you have to answer this. I think I
think by I think by age alone
The amount of sex you have is relative to your age?
Yeah, it goes upward on the line. >> How many times have
you had sex? Dickers, you're only a few years older than me.
Dickers, wait, Dickers, when you're when you're giving it to
these fat hoes as you call them
It can literally only go up as you age.
What? How many times have you had sex?
I I can't remember how many times I've had sex.
Give a ballpark, ballpark. On one hand, on two hands This is
like this is like my example of humor.
harassed women. How many times have I harassed women? I could
give you a ballpark.
Yeah, yeah.
Go on.
Okay, if we're just going to lie.
20-ish. I would Yeah, probably stand by 20-ish. Can you give
a ballpark? That sounds like it for one Like, is that per
No, how many You said You asked how many women I've
No, no, I said how many times have you harassed a woman?
Wait, wait, what's my record for harassing women? Obviously
I have had Were you going to say you had more than harassed assaulted
women or sorry, harassed women? Harassed women? Cuz that would
be insane. There's no way you're that confident. There's no way
you were going to deflect like that. If it's semi if it's semi-regular
behavior occurring, you obviously can't remember the exact number
of times. Well, you said ballpark, though.
Above or below 20? Above or below 20? He's just too much Above
or below 20? He's driving If you want to go If you want to go,
I don't know the number at all, it better be three digits if
you want to go, I have no idea what the number could possibly
I think anybody who's had like long-term relationships would
be triple digits,
Wait, Noel, so you you've had sex more than 20 times?
That's insane. >> We're not talking about body count, we're
just talking about number of times you've had sex. >> Number
of times you've had sex. Number Dickers, above or below 20?
Above? Above or below 100?
Above. I said it was triple digits, number of times I've had
>> sex a triple digit times. You've had sex above 100 times.
Over 100 times you've had sex.
I'm more amazed that this is amazing to Well, I'm just I'm just
trying to make sure I'm just No, we know that you're like lying.
We know you're lying.
I'm 20 I'm 20 We're pressing you cuz like you're lying. I've
been able to have sex the last eight years. You're also lying
about your age, as well. >> You're Wait, you're 26?
Did I say 26? He's 28. I don't know what You're 24 or 26, sorry.
24? >> He said 24, but he is 28.
So, you've been doing it every day?
So, wait, eight years eight years Dude, let's do some math. This
guy's lying like
So, eight years would like a 300 Let's say 300 times.
Right? That's one every like three days, let's say. every 10
days.
So, like there's no schedule? You don't like do it on the weekends?
It's like
Yeah, what if she's tired? Do you unite if she's tired? >> Yeah,
you're having sex every seven 9.73
days. You understand that, >> you have a clock for that?
Do you have a time to go off when you should eat your quota?
Is this scheduled Yeah, is this
Is it like a quarterly review? Do you do quarterly review the
whippings you do?
Dickers, this is why you look like a Well, I don't Okay. Okay,
you're not doing hour-plus sessions if you've had sex like 300
times, surely.
What are you What are you What What is that What is that question?
I've only had sex three times, and it's been multi-hour sessions
each of the three times, right? And I can justify that cuz it's
only been three times. It's like not that much in the grand scheme,
Each So, are you like a pump and dump? Like three minutes, maybe?
Multi-hour
each time. Yeah.
Who has this much time to give to a woman? Are you [__]
insane? Well, I gave up. I got bored and gave up. What?
Wait, what? Hold on. Let's say
Back to the relationships.
Back to Dickers. Let's try to stay on track.
Dickers, how long do you last? Three Yeah, Dickers, how hard
IS YOUR DICK?
DICKERS, I I'VE DONE THE MATH.
DONE THE MATH. If you've If you have sex If you have 300
300 times, and it's three minutes each time, 15 hours you've
had sex. That's what you're claiming?
It's a simple yes or no. I don't know why you're More. More.
More. More than 15 hours?
Well, across like a quarter of my life,
I just don't like when a girl inevitably makes a Google Doc about
you, uh people are going to look back on this stream
you know.
That's just I I mean, go ahead. Sorry, I interrupted you, I think.
Sorry.
No, no, go go ahead. No, I finished. I I I was just saying like
Like when a girl when a girl inevitably comes out about you,
people are going to cite this live stream to corroborate what
she's saying
because she's going to be arguing that you guys had less than
what you're
No, they won't. >> Based on other information in this stream,
we have a good reason to believe that the person writing that
doc will be Kinetic Kel.
Based on what we know from the stream
the person writing the doc will be Dickers' left hand.
You're left-handed?
Yeah, nice joke, Marai. Yeah, we're all
I I I I I I
I mean, I I wasn't trying to make a joke. I Dickers, you're left-handed?
No, Marai. I'm right-handed.
So, back to these fat hoes in these BDSM clubs that you be beating
the piss out with leather straps.
How often is that happening? Since you're having in the triple
digits over eight years. How long have you been in those clubs?
Beating fat hoes
exposed and de-hooded, obviously, with a leather strap. We have
to know.
Are we also in triple digit territory? Cuz you can I mean, I'm
You've probably been there for a while, you know. It's draining.
Some babies with the boys. I'm just asking. You just You just
did. You said you triple digits with your old lady. Or old man.
We don't judge here.
So, since you're open with that, why can't we get
Get an answer.
Well, listen, it's 2020 Listen, uh they come in all shapes and
sizes. Tell them, Dickers. Dickers would know, as he is a harsh
BDSM master who's had triple digit sex with a partner of the
past eight
I'd like to know.
You seem very comfortable answering that. That's more intimate.
If you go to Listen, I'm in a BDSM club. I don't give a [__]
who's in there.
But this [__] You're talking You're talking about
your old lady? You're dragging your old lady laundry up and down
the street?
That's kind of [__]
I think you should answer the BDSM master dungeon dungeon master
dom daddy question. Dickers?
Dickers, do you go to like porn movie
Like vintage porn movie theaters? Marai, you got to You got to
let that one hang, just so you know in future, Marai. You got
that one hang, okay?
You got to let that hang. Let Diggers hang in that Let what hang?
Let Let Diggers hang in that silence for a little bit, okay?
Let him marinate in that silence >> Oh, I get sorry. Sorry,
my bad.
No, it's fine.
It's fine. I'm going to continue on with the conversation. Feels
like we've hit Yeah, one person, bro. One person.
You are You are like low-blowing morale here really hard.
Low-blowing him?
No, um Little bro, as in a little brother, as in a younger brother,
as in you're treating him like he is uneducated on the topic
of being a harsh BDSM daddy master.
Back to you, Jason. >> I think
thank you. It's good clarification.
Morale, I would like to I would like to
I got triggered
by the fact that you were
That's okay. I think I think I'm definitely not as smart as you.
Um
I think I'm definitely not as smart as you, but I'd like to think
we're we're friends. And um I think even if you know that I'm
not as intelligent as you, you should probably
I would like it anyways if you gave me the respect and like treated
me as an equal, even even if I'm not really an
I think that's that's kind of what I want out of this. Does that
make sense?
I I understand that, Morale. I understand that. All right.
I appreciate it. When you were talking to that girl, you were
having vanilla, scared, trying to trepidation.
He's about to He's about to do the voice again, by the way. If
I remember correctly. Oh, I'm sorry for thrusting too hard, honey.
That is what you were having. See, that's almost exactly the
voice I did, BY THE WAY.
OH, I'M SORRY FOR THRUSTING TOO HARD, HONEY. That is what you
were having. That is what you were engaging in. Almost exactly
Almost one for one. I want to say 85% accuracy.
It is It's pretty good. It's pretty good. The first time?
Okay. Okay. >> After I lost my virginity, we got Subway
and watched the Batman movie, Robert Pattinson's Batman. It was
really cool. Okay. Okay. All All that I'm saying, okay, Is it
normal for a person to bleed you during Is that normal? How often
How often does that happen? And to be clear, okay, for the For
the people who don't know what I'm talking about, that's not
what I'm saying, right? And so, what I'm talking about, apparently,
is called postcoital bleeding. So, if you were engaging in vigorous
But postcoital >> What do you call its name?
Oh, my bad. My bad. Postcoital. So,
It's not like a girl is oozing on you
But it's going to be like I like to Can we Can we pause here
for a second?
This also seems like a topic you're very well educated on, cuz
you like pulled it out right off the top of your head. So, it
sounds like you're either a medical professional, which we know
you aren't,
or you've dealt with this quite often. So, how often are you
making women bleed in these BDSM nightclubs, where you're the
daddy dom master, beating their with the clitoris exposed, dehooded,
with a leather strap? We'd like to know.
I had I had received
allegations
over this take. So, I chose to familiarize myself.
Oh, I knew this is what it was. I called this Queenie confirm
that I called this when I said he googled this [__]
It's why he talked about the most It's the most common version
Or sorry, the most common cause of bleeding. Like you don't have
that statistic off the top of your
Absolutely had that, yeah. It's the most most common version
most most common version of bleeding. Yeah, okay. So, you you
just googled it.
Well, no, I think that was the original
Okay, I I might have melded this in my mind. Uh I might have
melded this in my mind. Okay, cuz I What I What I looked up previously
and what I looked up after.
All right. I feel like that's all I was thinking. >> Okay.
So, right, you know you know when women talk about, oh, he was
[__] By the way, Diggers, I sign up, just so you
know, I sign up to come on and have this same thing happen to
me over some stupid take I have in the future, okay, on your
stream. I'll come. I'll deal with everybody coming at me. Totally
Try to tear me down, okay?
I could barely walk the next day. Right?
I didn't remember he did it the third time. That's [__]
up.
I was Morale, I never speak to this guy again, quite frankly.
I mean, I've considered it.
What did I say? I just said something about That's awesome. Oh,
yeah, I cuz Diggers said like, what do you think women mean when
they say, I can't walk after having that good sex or whatever.
I thought that meant like you [__] their butt and
then it hurt It was like sore after, so that way they couldn't
sit down. >> think that? Or is that a meme? I brought that
up earlier, and everyone else apparently told me that was He's
still telling a joke right now, as well. He's still telling the
joke. It's a long No, no, I I cuz I I can't like It doesn't make
sense to me that a person would be sore after sex, because that's
kind of meant for to go into.
But like butt hole is not meant for to go inside of it. So, I
I would imagine it's more common for it to be sore after something
like that and like kind of hurt to sit down, maybe.
So, you thought that all good sex or whenever like, I can't stand
after, you know, I can barely walk the next day, you know, all
good sex basically is right now. Well, I thought I thought when
they gave when they said that specifically, they were referencing
Does that make sense? I told Jason we weren't joking about this
last night. I told I told him this. I I was on the page of it's
a joke and it's a funny bit, and I I laughed Jason said Jason
said What What did You were like
I I thought it was a bit. >> Morale's really funny. Morale's
really funny. Morale's more of a character than Perry is.
Yes. Well, I still Hold on. No, no, no. Wait. Yes, no Yes, yes,
yes. He's still more of a character than Perry is. Perry is way
less of a character. Perry is just Is that really what you think,
Jason Talks? I don't think I don't think Perry is like said any
discord I think that's I think I think what I portray is me.
right now. We're talking about how much of a goofy you both of
you are.
Oh, I see. Like you're just like this. >> not referencing
when they say that? Well, no, it led into a different conversation.
They're definitely Can Wait, so it When women have like sometimes
it like it hurts to walk. Was he Was he not here? Did he walk
away from the computer?
You know, he's still genuinely confused. He still genuinely thinks
that it's just It's when women are like, oh, I got [__]
too hard, I couldn't even walk straight that >> I'm fine
to take the L and I guess learning moment or whatever. I I thought
So, wait, you're you're
>> My Okay. I mean, oh, it's like when you work out and
you kind of get sore after. Yeah, like any muscle in your body,
I mean, my has never been sore.
Are you doing What's up, [__] This is like I think
this is a character. I don't think Morale is serious, cuz he
just he's he's getting 100% on the true or false. He's getting
it all wrong. He's getting 0%. I just don't think you would do
that consistently without being a character.
Yeah, [__] you myself again. Whatever, dude. [__]
you. No, it's funny. It's I don't need you to beat yourself.
I'm saying it's funny. I think it's a bit, but No, Morale, please
come back. You're so good. [__] off, Morale. I'll
beat yourself. I'll beat
I don't want to I don't want to have I mean, do I Do I First
of all, I don't talk to women about how they feel after sex.
And second of all, the few times that this that this has come
up in conversation, I just assumed it was
So, I I didn't question that, because it's like, you're you're
talking about anal, right? You're referencing anal, right? It's
like, do you want me to clarify with the women that I'm talking
to? Like, wait, so after this After the person they told me about
Are you afraid of being embarrassed now? Like this doesn't make
any sense. Quinnie, is this sufficient evidence to support my
point? Why would I be embarrassed to like women whom I'm trying
to
I feel like this is sufficient evidence to support my point.
I'll be real.
Oh, no response. You're You're aware that's how women talk about
that. their butt. Is that why they can't sit down?
Can be What What are you saying?
I said I feel Well, if you weren't listening, I feel like that
was all sufficient evidence to support my No, I was listening.
I was listening, He just keeps hitting He was saying Morale's
a guy. He keeps hitting in the funniest, stupid ways. Yeah.
I just don't I seriously don't think so. I I just don't think
he can miss that many times in a row. Um Despite what he says.
He's telling He's slipping in little jokes, but he I think the
fundamental thing that he's come from is true. I mean, I would
say
Yeah, the thing was true, yeah. He's just throwing out little
little jokes here and there that like, you know, maybe he's sort
of entertained the idea of one or two of those things before,
but he doesn't actually fully think
Yeah, yeah. >> It's just that That's what I assumed that
meant.
what that is, the reason that that's caused, okay, when you have
sex, is
tears, okay? That's what's actually caused that. You have torn
somebody's
torn her You've torn >> You're touching this guy right
now. Just Just so you know, you're You're You're touching You
tell this guy's a little goofy ass theater kid the way he's like
orating right now and like gesticulating. It makes me sick, man.
Can't stand this Dickers guy. Dude, I'm still reeling from the
comment. You guys have litigated for 5 minutes. It's so fresh
for me in this moment.
Okay. Do you want to keep talking about it, Dickers? Right.
About about you thinking that soreness after comes from
Yeah, I mean we can >> even that like a sticking point.
Like you We've already discussed that this guy's only had three
times, bro. Like what Can we get back to you? Well, in the nightclub
Yeah, I'm saying I'm saying the point is still fresh in my mind
as we speak.
Getting there paddled.
Back to you, Dickers.
I just Give us a number. >> to watch
I don't think we're getting a number. I just want to watch this
in slow motion. Dickers, what do you think you're communicating
to Marrow here with your gesticulation with the facial intonation?
Okay, hold on. This right
I feel like I'm I'm is oozing you're my little bro. You give
me a [__] headache when you talk like this. I can't
[__] believe you. Well, okay. Okay.
Well, I feel like I've talked I've found
who's willing to have a conversation about this on stream.
And unfortunately, I've been let down by the fact that they think
that soreness after is caused by doing it. Um I don't even think
you corrected me. You just like you we just moved past it. I
don't think. No, no. This is the
Watch this unmuted here.
>> Okay? That's what actually caused that. You have porn
somebody's
That's what causes that. Okay? And sometimes
I assume that that's how that happened, yeah. Yeah. And then
sometimes
Yeah. I feel like this is not on the the Hold on. The reason
that that's caused, okay? When you're back
Oh, actually, hold on. Are you saying that the reason women are
sore after can't walk is from tearing?
I Wait, hold on. Roll it back. Roll it back.
What that is, the reason that that's caused, okay? When you're
back
Wait, I didn't roll back far enough. That's I can't tell if it's
the bleeding or the soreness. We got to go back
Post coital. No, maybe it's the post coital bleeding.
Post coital. So, after the It's not like a girl is oozing on
you during sex. But it's going to be like Okay. So, right. You
know you know when women talk about oh, he was me so hard I could
barely walk the next day, right? Well, that's what we're talking
about. Now we're making a point. Can we pause
How often are you having this conversation, Dickers?
This is the this is the first time I've ever had to have this
conversation. >> No, not with Marrow. I'm talking about
you're talk you're saying
>> you know when women say, oh, I got [__]
so hard I I couldn't walk straight. How many times have you had
that conversation with a woman? You're saying, oh, you know when
women
I've never had this conversation with a with a woman. >> You've never
You've never heard a woman say that in your life.
No, cuz I'm not in the harsh BDSM daddy master classes where
I'm paddling leather straps.
And you are. You You have You have You have >> Let's get
a number. Let's get a number. How many times? You have. You have.
You >> I'm imagining big
leather leather X type cross and the fat women are upside down,
Dickers, cuz that's how you like them. The little folks on their
head
and you got their exposed.
And the is dehooded. And you're paddling them with a leather
strap and they're
And they're saying your name.
And this happens to you quite often. I want to know how often.
It's It's very
It's very interesting topic, you know?
>> after even without the iron comment. You You You You
listen to like a record and you're like, damn, I wonder how they
made that. Listen documentary of how they made the record. You're
the guy who made the record. I want to know how you did it. I
want to know what it was like. I want to know I want to Let's
get behind the music, Dickers.
or without the the physical abuse. I want to get behind the music.
How many times IS IT HAPPENING?
OH MY GOD. OKAY.
OKAY. OH MY GOD. OH MY GOD.
SO, WHAT THE [__] IS GOING ON? What's
I would never do that to you, Dickers. You see what this guy
just did? Oh my
That was [__] up. >> He's like, do you franchise
stock? I'll be the next Aiden. What the [__] IS GUYS
I'M JUST I'M PRODUCING right now, okay? I'm just making the funniest
content I can for the people watching. That's my only goal. That's
my only goal, man. That's my only
Okay, we we are making the point that Dickers is currently proposing
that the reason women are sore the next day from vigorous is
because of that bleeding. That is pretty clear to me here, right?
No, that's not what I'm claiming. Hold on. Slow down.
>> The reason for that is for micro tears.
Not bleeding.
Post coital bleeding is what happens when that gets into excess.
Okay, what? So, women are sore they can barely walk the next
day because of micro tears
in their
That's that's like definitely not the
What? You know women on the stream to talk about. What? What
Wait, wait. Someone Someone can bring that in if they want. No,
no, no. Jason, where does soreness comes
Soreness. Like like soreness in their muscles. Soreness So, soreness
in their muscles?
Well, they're doing muscle contractions They're doing keloids
during sex. That's what that's from. During during keloids during
Yeah, I hope women have muscle contractions during sex with you,
I don't I don't believe I don't believe that's that's what that's
from.
Did you mean ke- Kegels just now?
Cuz you said keloids twice.
What are ke- Wait, what the [__] are keloids? Oh,
it's like disgusting little growths on your hair, right? Kegels.
Just making sure. Just making sure. I wanted to just I'm just
making sure cuz like you're I I just wanted to make sure cuz
like you're teaching me things about how to be a harsh daddy
BDSM master.
I just want to make sure that I'm I'm I'm taking notes, Dickers.
Yeah, in my experience that's like muscle soreness from muscle
contractions, either somebody being on top, lots of different
reasons it could happen. Um but usually Hold on. Listen, I'm
I'm grokking this [__] right now. Dickers, Dickers,
let me save you, okay? Let me help you, okay? It's not from micro
tears inside.
stop. I'm just trying to help you, okay?
Wait, what is my mic? What happened?
I think it's Yeah, your mic's plugged
No, is my mic bugging?
Yeah, your mic's plugged in. Wait, did you like Are you Wait,
did you not kick her? She like left in the middle of a sentence,
>> Okay. Hold on. 2 seconds.
2 seconds and grok. Dickers, you should grok You should grok
this. Grok um
something like this. It It'd be like a When a woman says she's
too sore to walk a day after sex, is it from micro tears or from
muscle soreness? Grok that. I think I think it's deal I think
Dickers is saying
tears in muscles cause soreness after Soreness after sex. No,
no, no, no, no. No. No. Use the phrasing that you used.
When women say things like too sore to walk, too sore to sit
down,
ask for what that generally is referring to in in grok. Can you
give me your
Wait, you give me your your prompt was just soreness after sex.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, I think you need to do the the bit here.
And grok the savior. Dickers, I think you should pull it up live.
I think you should live stream you grokking it right
What is What is the uh What is the prompt we want to put in?
>> Wait, sorry. Do we think that that's We think that's
going to be like fundamentally different if there's like soreness
after sex and then they're walking and what? Nothing is moving
about? I'll be clear. Soreness
Soreness next day after sex.
So, this the soreness after sex due to micro vaginal tears and
then that's not going to have
the next day completely resolved within 24 hours? It's crazy
how this He He probably gets away with this in like other conversations
with people where he just like the whole thing we've talked about.
What? Oh my Jesus Christ. I don't know if he's saying anything.
Like I don't know if I'm just I don't know if I have the IQ to
understand what he's saying. Cuz he he will just like squirm
around. It's crazy what I'm seeing. I'm going to say
Here we go. Here we go. Now we've got this. No, we We said we'd
grok it. When a woman says she's so sore she can barely walk
the day after in a good way, what is that normally referred to?
All right, let's go.
Are we leaving it to God? Are we good on this one? Yeah, roll
the dice. Roll the dice. Let's go. Roll the dice? I feel like
Rock's going to be stupid on this. Micro vaginal tearing. Oh,
Rock's playing five dice on this. We have to we have to get Elon.
Oh, tissue irritation.
Pelvic floor. >> Almost always refers to muscle soreness.
Oh, first one up, too. First one is muscle soreness.
First one up. >> on. Hold on. Can we go to number two?
Most common things it actually means in the positive in this
positive context, pelvic floor, core, hip muscle fatigue.
Now, the second one is
tissue irritation from friction or stretching. Oh, micro tears.
Yes, go. You're you're on the board, Diggers. Theory says, yes.
No, but like have you seen No, but I'm taking two and three.
I'm taking two and three. I'm taking two and three. No, but have
you seen like Family Feud, though? No, but have you seen Family
Feud and like the number one point will be
like 25 points and the next two will be 10 and four.
Mhm. So, I I got the answer correct is what you're telling me?
You said most common, correct? >> disgraceful stuff. I
is disgraceful stuff. I need you to I need you to nail that down.
>> Run the clip back. Run the clip back. Run the clip back.
>> Listen, this can all be avoided if you tell us right
now how many fat women
you have paddled the butts of
with the crucifix deleted upside down on a leather cross.
I've I've already said it. >> BDSM daddy master nightclub
setting. >> I've I've already said innumerable.
It's not a number.
You can't put a number on it.
Jestock, I'm submitting evidence to the >> How many stars
are in the sky, Skyler?
I'm not pulling that one up. I'm sorry.
>> Oh, not pulling it up. Why are you not pulling this
one up? I'm not pulling that one up. Cuz it's already getting
to be a lot.
Let's scroll down. I I like let's like actually like scroll down
to when it's not a good thing. I'm just interested in that answer.
Can you just scroll down a little bit?
When it's not a good  fun thing. If the soreness is actually
severe, sharp, burning, one-sided, lasts greater than three to
four days, usual discharge is Okay, this is talking about
Which if we run the conversation with morale back, I said that
since it was lasting for three days, yeah, I didn't realize that.
That's bad.
Run back the clip about not walking right, whatever. Jestock,
pull pull that. Run it back. Roll back. Roll back. You were engaging
in like vigorous We can run it. We can run it back to the All
right, so we talked about it lasting for I learned that and then
I changed my And since Batman >> Yes, it's a different
take. We're doing that's a different thing, but Wait, how much
How much credit back is that?
How much credit back is >> I'm giving the That's when I'm
giving the disclaimer.
So, I I actually open with that.
You you're applying what you said to the to this.
Well, no, no, we're saying that it's it's not good if it's over
three days. And I say, damn, that's true.
That's what I said, yeah.
Yeah, but this is a separate thing where you're saying this is
a good thing.
If you you're saying like if you've ever heard a woman say oh,
he was [__] me so hard I I could I was sore the next
day, whatever. >> Yeah, and so that would still fall under
that. That would still fall under that. That would still fall
under the good. I didn't say that it was good even, but I'll
accept that for the sake of that it's like acceptable, right?
Mhm, I reject that. The way you're The way you're talking about
it The way you're talking about it in this context
In this context, you are saying it's a good thing. You are doing
a voice where it's like you're doing the voice of like the most
satisfied woman in the world.
Yes or no? So, are you doing the voice of the most satisfied
woman in the world when you say that? Okay. I would be a good
thing and then you're pointing to the bad part where it's lasting
for an extended period of time. I already said that's when I
changed my
Oh, I wasn't really Somebody asked me to read it. I wasn't referencing
that for any particular reason, to be honest with you. Oh, that's
what I was referencing.
Okay. Yeah.
And to be clear, okay. For the For the people who don't know
what I'm talking about, that's not what I'm saying, right? And
so what I'm talking about apparently is called postcoital bleeding.
So, if you were engaging in like vigorous What postcoital gets
its name?
Postcoital.
Oh, my bad. My bad. >> Postcoital, so after
It's not like a girl is losing on you
But it's going to be like Okay, so right, you know you know when
women talk about oh, he was [__] me so hard I could
barely walk the next day, right? You're you're you're aware that's
a common trope of women talking about that? their butt, so that
way they can't sit down and it like hurts to sit. That's what
I assumed that meant.
No, no, no, no, no. Okay.
what that is, the reason that that's caused, okay, when you're
about to
tears, okay? That's what's actually caused that. You have torn
somebody's
That's what causes that. Okay? This is definitive. This is not
even in the word. This is This is not what's really being described.
When someone says that, that's not really what's being described.
It isn't usually tears. Tears is probably going to be like, you
know, like tears like you're like stinging. It's not like sore.
It's not like uh No, no, it's like micro tears. It's not like
lesions or like gashes. But it would it's like covered in mucus.
>> like it's like friction on the >> having an ulcer.
Ulcers aren't massive.
What are you talking about, man?
What? It would sting. I don't I don't know where you got ulcers
>> They're having a mild abrasion. I'm
an ulcer is not a big cut.
It's like tiny abrasions.
Correct? And that's what would cause
No, it would it would sting, not be sore. It would it would be
stinging, not
This is the distinction we need to come down to now, the difference
between >> that's what's being described, Diggers. We're
talking about We're talking about micro tears, not gashes in
somebody's from having Obviously that doesn't make any what's
being described
in the [__] [__] off. It makes a difference.
It makes
Yeah, it does cuz you're describing
Stinging and soreness makes a big difference. So, that makes
a big Diggers, if you have ever lifted weights in your entire
life, you would know the difference between stinging and soreness.
Oh my god.
Diggers, why don't you hit the gym, bro? Your shirts looking
a little tight,
Diggers, you must understand it's a different like if you graze
like your knee or something, right? >> That's like a child.
You went outside,
>> You you you graze You graze your knee
as a kid it like stings, right? Cuz you've got a tiny little
abrasion. >> I'm saying, okay, what I'm saying is that
that would be like a cut along cuz you've like grated your [__]
like knee or whatever the [__] That is not a micro
tear. That is just a tear.
That's just a wound. What do you think makes What What do you
think the difference is here in
the mechanics or like the sensation? What do you think is the
difference?
The size Is the surface area? Like how big the wound is?
Okay, why is it changing?
And how?
The The feeling, presumably.
Wait, can we go back Can we go back to What way would it change?
What way would it change? We're describing micro tears as
Oh, yeah, sure. Um
it's basically that you get like swelling and uh swelling and
soreness from micro tears due to friction. Where I had this stupid
[__] Rock post. Hold on, right here.
Upper vaginal largest size, less natural lubrication than ideal.
Micro tears, swelling and low-grade inflammation in the back
walls, entrance, or lips.
It actually doesn't say that micro tears are like >> line.
Hold on. Second line. Second line.
I'll give you friction and pain.
>> No, no, no. It often feels like general tenderness or
aching rather than sharp pain. Usually peaks within 12 to 48
hours later, delayed onset.
What do you think is funny about Yeah, what what what's there
in there? This is not like a sharp pain
like a sting would be. It's like soreness or tenderness or aching.
Diggers, if you've never ridden a bike in your life, Diggers.
This is the whole point, by the way. It literally Diggers, there
is obviously a difference between muscle soreness
and the tenderness
of a abraded or torn micro torn area of
There's obviously a difference in the sensation there. There's
going to be. Just mechanically
Would you say that a sting is not a sharp pain?
Cuz I would say that soreness is like an So, micro micro tears
are going to be smaller and greater in number, so they're going
to feel less like a specific sting in a spot and more like a
>> it's going to be like distributed, yeah. Yes, but that's
different to a muscle
different to muscle soreness >> Tears in your muscle fiber,
possibly? Like soreness that you get Oh, you do not No, you don't
get to move. You don't get to move. You don't get to move from
micro tears. That micro tears and muscle fibers. That is such
an insane pivot right there. That's such an insane pivot. It's
crazy. Muscle soreness. Hello, Ico. Hey, so I just wanted to
say clear this up, Diggers. When when a woman is like, oh man,
they [__] me so good. I you know, I couldn't walk
the next day.
Uh put your hood back up, Silent. You'll be fine. Okay.
No one means, "Oh wow, I feel like very like uh like a abrasive
irritation in my vagina. That's so cool." No one's talking about
that. What? Yuck.
Ico, do they mean anyone that happens sometimes? No, bro. I don't
know how you are such a degenerate, but also you can come off
as so like naive and innocent. It's I don't know how work. I
didn't know that there was Can we can we cut the teaching role
play that's going on right now? Are you kidding? Stylo, you say
such crazy
Yeah, but it was like that's part of the that's the point. I'm
there's no tension here. What? The boys.
I I mean, you >> I would lay you down like a [__]
bath mat, lady.
He probably do that to you, too. Is that like a weight joke?
Sorry, continue.
Um I just wanted to be clear cuz yeah, Stickers is I think this
is a good learning experience for Stickers to speak with less
confidence
about things over other people.
I I really appreciate Stickers so much, but this is I think youth
and hubris. So I'm just here to throw that down, okay?
I think I I think Stickers will appreciate the guy that's counseling
I think it's just undeniable. Undeniable.
Dickers in this clip >> Dickers, maybe you should have
been nicer to Ico yesterday. Maybe you shouldn't have said like
you don't even remember your calling you stupid. Maybe you shouldn't
have said that to her, eh? Do you think about that? Yeah, true.
You're You're true. You lashed out like a And maybe you shouldn't
have tried to low blow brow or having sex. Wait, wait. No, no.
This is important. This is important. We need to speak We need
to finish this. We need to finish this.
In that clip, Stickers, you say like as a matter of fact, the
reason why women
that I struggled to walk the next day whatever. Felt sore walking
the next day whatever whatever the phrasing was. The reason why
they say that is because micro tears. Now, that isn't even the
number one reason why they would say that. You can argue a secondary
like it is it's like a secondary potential thing, but even though
it doesn't it doesn't really fit. It does not really
Are these rounds or these arbitrarily listed? I mean, it's whatever.
Okay,
It's not what's being described there. It's not what is being
described there. It generally that is not pinhole like a [__]
like a like a bug like a bug to squeeze through to the other
side of the [__] wall, and it's not working, Stickers.
Stickers, you've been walked down in every other point except
for the harsh BDSM Daddy Master.
Yeah, look. It's
I've actually got to go to bed. I'll chat to you guys later.
HOPEFULLY
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR 2 HOURS. WAIT, how much do you have to donate
to your stream to finish the clip with us? How much do you need
to donate to your stream to finish the clip? I assume that's
how that happened, yeah. Yeah, and then sometimes if you're going
to have sex three times in one day and engage in CNC dynamics,
then yes, okay. There might be a little bit given the fact that
the vagina is a moist internal organ. I just assumed a slight
a slight bloody discharge. They be pushing like like horse up
there, and then also they give birth to babies, which are also
bigger than horse.
So I in my mind, I just assumed, okay, even if Tom's like hung
like a horse,
I would assume they could take it. I would assume that they're
built for
But I could You know, I'm I'll take the L. I'll take the L. Um
Could be wrong.
I don't think the average the average woman is putting horse
up there up
I don't think so. Average girl I think you've got to train for
that.
You have to train?
I don't know. I don't know.
up your
Yeah, I think you've probably probably got to work work your
way up there, okay? It goes human, cow, hippopotamus, then you
get to horse, okay? And then dragon. I don't know how the [__]
you hippopotamus and cow from?
I was like I In In my mind watching this for the first time,
I was thinking What's going on? I love. What I got like I got
like five messages telling me to join while I was cooking.
Have I ever had That's my main hole, baby. Does it like hurt
to walk when you're done? Oh god, bro. I was about to be validated.
>> Does it hurt to sit down like after any
Oh, no. Could it? Like could you see a world in which that could
happen? You lost. You lost.
I don't I'd I mean,
it hurts to sit after some abnormal sometimes. Yes, hold on.
Hold on. You're blowing my mind right now. You're blowing my
[__] mind. It hurts to sit It hurts to sit after
normal but not after
I mean, like if you hard enough, yeah.
But it's like normal
shouldn't leave you like incapacitated just like normal
I'm out of my depth. I'm going to I'm going to mute. I'm sorry.
All right, Lab. Why would you Why what what reason would you
give for why it is hard to sit down after sometimes?
Uh well, The next day The next day The next day The next day
So the next day you could barely walk. What do you think the
most common >> sore, stupid? Well, there's no such I mean,
if you're sore the next day to where you can barely walk, you
have like vaginismus or something. That's like not
If you It doesn't Sometimes sometimes when someone is very large,
there are micro tears, and it and it stings a little bit, but
there's It should never hurt so much that you can't walk. I don't
think that exists or unless you've got like a cervix injury.
What's vaginismus?
Vaginismus is like a condition where you have It It just means
like painful
Wait, that's literally what it means?
So Katerino had like just a really tight Yeah, J start pulling
stuff real quick.
What do you mean?
I don't I'm sorry. What is What is tightness? What is the
There's like this drama like 5 years ago with a girl called Katerino,
and she misfit character fits. She had like a tight
How do you know it was tight? Because she said that she had vaginismus,
and it was really hard to put his [__] inside of
her. It's like a call me Carson drama. So vaginismus can actually
make your vagina looser. It doesn't really have a bearing on
So do you think that Katerino was lying and that maybe Fits just
had like a big
what vaginismus can do is paralyze your pelvic floor,
which means that you can't like grab the vagina with your vaginal
muscles. It also could mean that like you don't get wet, which
can make it painful.
Doesn't necessarily mean tightness.
Thank you, miss.
Okay, can I just point out that Lab said tears, and on that note,
I'm going to go
Wait, you get your cervix bruised more than you get your torn?
Can you get it bruised more? I'm asking you specifically.
Micro tears Uh sorry, more than more than your more than you
get micro tears, you get your cervix bruised. Just say what's
more likely like a normal person who knows English.
Uh I It literally I don't know. It depends. It depends.
There's no like clear answer for that. You're dismissed. Thank
you, ma'am. You're dismissed. No, no. Now I have to say You can
stay, Lab, if you want. You can hang out. Yeah, thanks for the
permission. Dickers Dickers has to go to his late night harsh
Daddy BDSM Master nightclub. What the He's on his way there right
now. That's what I do, to be fair. That is what I do.
That's scary. Lab, if you hooked up with a boy and he gave you
ringworm, would you continue that relationship or end it? boy
and we're like adults. A boy really? Well, yeah. How How old
is the boy? Like 13? Like 22. Okay, okay. Calm down, Ralph. Calm
down,
Isn't Tom 22?
I only have people who I've known for like a while
and I'm pursuing a relationship with. So if they happen to give
me
If they happen to give me ringworm, I would probably be If I
liked them enough to have sex with them, I'd probably
I'd probably be not okay with it, but I'd be like, "What the
heck?" And then that wouldn't make me leave, no. Lab, would you
be open to making a diss track with me on Turkey Tom for a YouTube
video? I don't know anything about Turkey Tom. You don't need
to know anything about it. It's okay. I feel like I might have
to. He called you old and a beat like 2 years ago?
Old and beat like when I was 25 years
Yeah. Given the Given the recent circumstances, that makes sense.
Do you want to make a diss track, Lab?
Um no. I don't think so. Okay, thanks anyways.
I appreciate the offer, though.
Let's see. What are we doing here? I'm going to go start wrapping
my stream. I'll be back in like 10 minutes or
Yeah, sure. Sure.
Okay, thanks. You got anything else you wanted to throw in or
Um I just wanted to point out the fact that we looked into it,
and yeah, tears can be a contributing factor to soreness in walking
after sex. In fact, it can be a contributing
Hold on. Hold on, hold on. Now you Now you've said something
outrageous again. Now you said something outrageous again. You
are acting like I was a complete for not knowing that this is
the thing that happens and you were unaware of another thing
that happens
I was I was I was dead set on defending my take. I apologize.
Uh-huh. Okay. What was your take?
Um that vigorous intercourse by fuzz that can lead to post coital
bleeding.
It's your opinion. Each sex for three times in one day. This
guy is incapable. This guy is incapable of actually summarizing
his take in a good faith way. Kleiman was totally correct in
pressing you on that by the way. I didn't think so. I thought
it was too far, but you are completely incapable of actually
in a good faith way summarizing your take in a good faith way.
Go to bed, bro. You summarize my take for me. Okay. I'll do that.
In a good faith way.
Have a good night. Thank you for coming on and I will sign up
for this similar, you know, whatever this was again. You find
a take I have that's stupid. I promise I'll come on. Okay. Have
a good one, mate. You get everybody to Yeah. All right. See you.